- I don't think I got to ask you
this last time you were here,
but how did you and your husband meet?
'Cause I know, Matt is
an incredible writer.
He literally wrote one
of my favorite songs I've ever recorded.
"Someone."
Like, he's so talented.
So how did y'all meet?
Was it while you were
working, like in the studio?
- Yeah, well, yes.
So we got set up, we are both at RCA.
And we got set up by our A&R person there,
just not set up like that,
but just set up to work.
- Yeah.
- And I was like cutting
a couple of the songs
that he had written.
- So good.
- And we met at Aroma Cafe
on Tujunga, in the Valley.
And then we ended up being there
for like two hours talking.
And I was like, "(gasps) I gotta go.
What am I doing?
Why are we talking about
all these like '90s music
that we like and like
really connecting and-"
- Because you're cool
and 90s music is awesome.
- Yeah.
- So that's how we met.
And then we recorded a
little bit in the studio
and everything was pretty professional.
And then he asked me out on a date,
it was around Valentine's Day.
And then we like casually,
kind of started dating
like a month after that.
And we broke up and then
we got back together
and then we broke up and
then we got back together.
- Oh you did?
- And we were like,
"we shoulda have a baby."
- Oh! (laughing)
- And then we had a baby
and I was like, "if any
of my kids not do that,
you're all gonna die."
(Kelly laughing)
But it worked out really great for us.
- Oh my god, I love this story.
This is a movie.
You should produce this movie
- And like two weeks later,
I was pregnant.
- Oh my gosh.
- I know.
I know, naughty.
- But he's so funny.
- He's so funny.
I mean, here's the thing,
I feel like if someone can make you laugh.
- [Hillary] I know.
- Like, you know what
I'm saying, love changes,
it doesn't necessarily fade,
it just changes, I feel like.
But like, if someone can make you laugh,
like that's what we're all looking for.
'Cause that's always gonna
be awesome to be around.